all right well Tim Scott's Republican
Presidential candidacy off to an
explosive start opening the event in
North Charleston South Carolina with a
Dean scream I'll explain in a moment
then plagued by Audio issues you all
know I love it when these right Wingers
have audio issues
exactly right
um and then just saying completely
outrageous things and his campaign does
appear to be dead on arrival so as I
told you yesterday Republican senator
from South Carolina Tim Scott the only
black Republican in the Senate has
announced he is running for president of
the United States against Donald Trump
why Maga voters would switch from a
candidate who regularly scapegoats black
and brown people to a black guy I don't
know it doesn't seem like that's going
to appeal to them but
here is Tim Scott opening the event with
the dean's scream
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
stuff for people who don't remember the
dean's scream this was the moment in
2014 that ended Howard Dean's
presidential chances and I'm not saying
it was right I'm just saying it happened
and then we're going to Washington D.C
to take back the White House
[Applause]
exactly a moment that will live in
infamy uh Tim Scott in very melodramatic
fashion but this is all so stupid guys
in melodramatic fashion building to the
big announcement and I guess you could
say the crowd went wild I don't know you
tell me not less
we cannot have innocent people at risk
police officers getting ambushed and
attacked and seniors locked in their
homes from the time the sun goes down
until the sun comes up
Joe Biden and the radical left are
attacking every single rung of the
latter that helped me climb
and that's why
I'm announcing today
that I'm running
for president
of the United States
of America
all right
so anyway certainly a lot of energy
there happening
um and uh
he also made the strange claim that he's
the candidate the left is most scared of
which is interesting I'm the candidate
the far left fears the most
the far left is like who are you again
[Applause]
you see
when I cut your taxes
they called me a prop uh-oh when I
refunded the police
they called me a token
when I pushed back on President Biden
they even called me the n-word
the audience is like I disrupt their
narrative I threatened their control the
truth of my life
disrupts their lives there you go I
don't know that the Republican audience
is going to go for this that's my sense
folks and we'll look at the polling in a
moment I I can't gloss over the massive
audio issues that they had and I'm
actually going to play for you the the
it feels like it goes on forever but it
doesn't I love this stuff America
is not a nation
uh-oh so the audio has now cut out
someone starts signaling him he's asking
which microphone is causing the problem
he's tapping his microphone he's wearing
a lapel mic and holding one he's
switching it on and off now he steps
forward it's getting awkward he's
talking into it but it's totally dead he
seemed to check his feet as if he had
like stepped on a cable and then now I
guess someone is going to maybe bring
him a different mic
okay now he's been handed a third
microphone this one's wired and it's
also not working he's talking into
multiple mics now and then he does he's
now he has the mic reversed almost about
to talk into the back end of the
microphone and then tapping the lapel
holding two mics and wearing a third one
this is unbelievable and now there's
cheering okay
and now he's back they were able to
survive the audio problems that's for
sure but I think Eric they're not like
they lived up I used to check it every
week are they buying are they buying
okay so
how this is the dumbest Republican
primary how is Tim Scott doing not
particularly well he has opened up this
race with an explosive
1.8 percent support behind at half the
level of support of Vivek ramaswamy
well behind Nikki Haley and Far Behind
Mike Pence who isn't even a candidate I
think it's important to know that being
said Tim Scott is ahead of Larry Elder
and I didn't even know Larry Elder was
considering running or that anyone was
thinking of Larry Elder as a candidate
but needless to say 1.8 percent it is
undeniable that Tim Scott's campaign is
completely dead on arrival but there's
someone that seems to be gushing with
excitement for Tim Scott and that's the
crew over at Fox and Friends on Fox News
let's talk about that next one of our
sponsors today is fume not everything in
a bad habit is wrong so instead of a
drastic uncomfortable change why not
just remove the bad part from your habit
fume is an Innovative award-winning
device that does exactly that fume is
not electronic there's no Vapor or
harmful chemicals fume is just a
delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult difficult to
do but switching to fume is easy and
enjoyable there's no reason that you
can't be the next fume success story
head on over to trifum.com and use the
code Pacman to save 10 when you get the
journey pack which comes with the device
and three flavors the link is down below